good morning John I'm still sick this is
annoying a thing that I've noticed now
that I've had this happening point two
weeks is that when you are sick people
give you advice I've actually noticed
this for years when it comes to my
ulcerative colitis a lot of people seem
to have a cure in their back pocket only
I'd go gluten free or stop eating grains
or go paleo or vegan or stop eating
short-chain carbohydrates or fast for
three days and then eat an apple
seriously it was a whole thing and it
took like half the party for him to
explain it to him and over the years I
tried a lot of those things and none of
them worked what worked was taking the
medicine that my doctor gave to me and
then were the past week people have been
saying completely normal things to me
like get some rest man or take it easy
stop stressing sleep more and I've been
a little bit shocked by how annoying
this is not because it is annoying like
it's fine it's a totally fine thing for
somebody to say but it's tapping into
this thing that I have with my
ulcerative colitis four years of dealing
with my chronic illness that I cannot
cure and having people tell me ways that
I should be able to cure it what I'm
hearing is not you know take it easy we
support you instead I'm hearing I have
the secret to your wellness and if only
you had the courage and fortitude to
implement it you would no longer be sick
and one step further from that what's
tickling my subconscious here is this
idea that my illness is my fault
I know that my chronic illness is pretty
insignificant compared with what a lot
of other people are dealing with but I
think this is probably an experience
that a lot of people have when you tell
me a person who has lived with
ulcerative colitis for more than a
decade that you have the secret to my
wellness I cannot help but dislike you
like if that's my first impression and
sometimes it is I'm like I'm out and
look maybe this is the one weird
instance in which you are the one who
was right and maybe I'm missing that
opportunity to finally make myself
better and I've heard this line so many
times with so many different fads and so
many different pieces of anecdotal
evidence that all I can hear when people
say this to me is your illness is your
fault because we want it to be something
small right because if it's not the
fault of anything then it has to be just
weird random chance and that's what
chronic illness is it's just freaking
happens to good people and a bad people
and to champion athletes and people who
drink too much I've dealt with my
illness by allowing myself to accept it
by admitting
myself and accepting that my life is
different now and that my body is
different now and I have to live inside
of this body that sometimes hurts itself
science will keep marching forward and
someday maybe there will be a medicine
that I can take that will control this
disease without making me sick in other
ways and yes science shows that my
behavior does influence the expression
of my disease and so does my experience
of my disease and so I do need support
from people to help me make the
decisions that my doctor says that I
should make and that I have decided for
myself that I want to me but I also
can't avoid the truth that this is the
body that I'm in and I have to accept
that like among the many probabilities
that were cast that mostly came up in my
favorite I rolled bad on autoimmune
diseases my brain has tried to tell me
over and over again that this is my
fault
I have searched for every possible way
subconsciously and consciously that this
is a thing that I did to myself and
that's a crappy feeling and it is really
that there's a simple thing that I could
do to make myself well I want to see
here at the end of this video I'm doing
fine I'm not angry or frustrated my
friends are at you I have a loving
supportive group of people who are
fantastic in my life and I do my best to
understand that when people are saying
these things they're not trying to make
me feel what I'm feeling so I just try
and accept that support for what it is
rather than how it's being expressed
specific but if you want to be
supportive to someone who's sick in your
life make sure that you recognize that
it's very possible that they are
struggling right now with this feeling
that they did something to cause or to
deserve the illness they have even if
objectively they understand that that's
completely untrue when we say there's an
easy way out of this and there's not
what we're making people feel is that
this is your fault when it's not John
I'll see you on Tuesday